thank you
I want things to say the way they are
can't stop time Wendy
whether you like it or not
[Music]
he was flying a little bug did it
I think that's a bug
she is a fairy
are you Peter Pan were you expecting
someone else
[Music]
that's Neverland is this everything you
dreamed of I could never have dreamed of
this
where is this place no rules no schools
no bedtimes and most of all no growing
up are you Wendy
Peter Peter
Captain it's Peter Pan
ever say
his name
[Music]
don't touch my brother
miss me just like old times all your
times are old captain
come on
did you hear that
that is one big
[Music]
to grow up might just be just be the
biggest adventure of all
foreign